[Musique]
carten chevalier noir encore des chiens
ou encore des ennuis
devrait utiliser les techniques de ton
show vidéo leur donner une bonne raclée
oui mais ici c'est le monde réel ça n'a
rien à voir c'est quoi ça ça appartient
à ma famille depuis toujours je la mets
au situe l'emmener chez toi ouais alors
c'est toi le chevalier noir dans le jeu
vidéo wii dans ce monde je suis jack
branson
j'ai besoin de toi pour payer sur le
plus précieux trésor de l'empiré de quoi
tu parles
la route
bienvenue dire comment je vais faire
pour sortir je suis coincé ici
oh
[Musique]
on trouvait à princesse vous savez où
elle est à bientôt demain à la même
heure nous serons mari et femme je
préfère mourir que d'être ta rennes
tu as le choix de sauver ta peau ou de
l'assaut mais je sais pas me battre
prends-moi deux trois trucs que je
puisse me défendre
tu es le chevalier noir se fait oublier
tu m'as toujours été un guerrier jack
tu es venu me sauver
et voilà maintenant sauteurs
[Musique]